you mentioned something in a stream
about the philosophical nature of time
so uh let's start with the wild question
do you think time is an illusion
you know I sell phone calls uh to comma
for a thousand dollars uh and some guy
called me and uh like you know it's a
thousand dollars you can talk to me for
for half an hour and he's like uh yeah
okay so like time doesn't exist and I
really wanted to share this with you
I'm like oh what do you mean time
doesn't exist right like I think time is
a useful model whether it exists or not
right like does quantum physics exist
well it doesn't matter it's about
whether it's a useful model to describe
reality is time maybe compressive
do you think there is an objective
reality or is everything just useful
models
like Underneath It All Is there an
actual thing that we're constructing
models for
I don't know
I was hoping you would know I don't
think it matters I mean this kind of
connects to the models of constructive
reality with machine learning
right sure like is it just nice to have
useful approximations of the world such
that we can do something with it so
there are things that are real column
graph complexity is real
yeah yeah the compressive thing math is
real yeah
this would be a T-shirt and I think hard
things are actually hard I don't think P
equals NP oh strong words well I think
that's the majority I do think factoring
is in P but I don't think you're the
person that follows the majority in all
walks of life so but it's good for that
one I do yeah in theoretical computer
science you you're one of the Sheep
all right but do you uh times a useful
model sure
what were you talking about on the
stream what time are you made of time if
I remembered half the things I said on
stream uh someday someone's gonna make a
model of all of it and it's going to
come back to haunt me someday soon yeah
probably
would that be exciting to you or sad
that there's a George hotz model
I mean the question is when the George
hotz model is better than George tots
like I am declining and the model is
growing what is the metric by which you
measure better or worse in that if
you're competing with yourself
maybe you can just play a game where you
have the George Haas answer and the
georgetown's model answer and ask which
people prefer
people close to you or strangers
either one it will hurt more when it's
people close to me but
both will be overtaken by the
georgetown's model
it'd be quite painful right loved ones
family members would rather have the
model over for Thanksgiving than you
yeah
or like significant others
would rather sext
with the uh with the large language
model version of you
especially when it's fine-tuned to their
preferences
yeah well that's what we're doing in a
relationship right we're just
fine-tuning ourselves but we're
inefficient with it because we're
selfish ingredients on all language
models can fine-tuned more efficiently
more selflessly there's a Star Trek
Voyager episode where uh you know
Catherine Janeway
lost in the Delta quadrant makes herself
a lover on the Holodeck and
um
the lover falls asleep on her arm and he
snores a little bit and you know Janeway
edits the program to remove that
and then of course the realization is
wait this person's terrible it is
actually all there uh
nuances and quirks and slight annoyances
that that make this relationship
worthwhile
but I don't think we're going to realize
that until it's too late
well I think a large language model
could incorporate the the flaws and the
quarks and all that kind of stuff just
the perfect amount of quirks and floor
flaws to make you charming without
crossing the line yeah yeah
and that's probably a good like
approximation of the like the percent of
time the language model should be uh
cranky or uh
an or jealous or all this kind
of stuff and of course it can and it
will but all that difficulty at that
point is artificial there's no more real
difficulty
okay what's the difference in real and
artificial artificial difficulty is
difficulty that's like constructed or
could be turned off with a knob real
difficulty is like you're in the woods
and you've got to survive
so if something cannot be turned off
with a knob it's real
yeah I think so or I mean you can't get
out of this by Smashing the knob with a
hammer
I mean maybe you kind of can you know I
into the wild when uh you know uh
Alexander Supertramp he wants to explore
something that's never been explored
before but it's the 90s everything's
been explored so he's like well I'm just
not going to bring a map
yeah I mean
no you're you're not exploring you
should have brought a map dude you died
there was a bridge a mile from where you
were camping
how does it connect to the metaphor of
the knob
by not bringing the map you didn't
become an explorer
you just smashed the thing yeah yeah the
art the difficulty is still artificial
we failed before you started what if we
just don't have access to the knob well
that maybe is even scarier
right like we already exist in a world
of Nature and nature has been fine-tuned
over billions of years yeah
um to uh have
uh
humans build something
and then throw the knob away in some
Grand romantic gesture is horrifying
do you think of us humans as individuals
that are like born and die or is it are
we just all part of one living organism
that is earth that is nature
I don't think there's a clear line there
I think it's all kind of just fuzzy I
don't know I mean I don't think I'm
conscious I don't think I'm anything I
think I'm just a computer program
so it's all computation that I think
running in your head is just a is a this
computation everything running in the
universe is computation I think I
believe the extended Church starting
thesis
yeah but it there seems to be an
embodiment to your particular
computation like there's a consistency
well yeah but I mean models have
consistency too
yeah models that have been rlh after
will continually say you know like well
how do I murder ethnic minorities oh
well I can't let you do that Hal there's
a consistency to that behavior
it's all rlhf
like we all our lhf each other we we
find we uh provide human feedback and in
there that
thereby fine-tune these little pockets
of computation but it's still unclear
why that pocket of competition stays
with you like for years it just kind of
fall like you have this consistent
set of
um physics biology
uh what like whatever you call the the
neurons firing the electrical centers
the mechanical signals all of that that
seems to stay there and it contains
information stores information and that
information permeates Through Time
and stays with you there's like memory
it's like sticky okay to be fair like a
lot of the models we're building today
are very even rlhf is nowhere near as
complex as the human loss function
reinforcement learning with human
feedback
um you know when I talked about will GPT
12 be AGI my answer is no of course not
I mean cross-century loss is never going
to get you there you need
uh probably rln
fancy environments in order to get
something that would be considered like
agi-like
so to ask like the question about like
why I don't know like it's just some
Quirk of evolution right I don't think
there's anything particularly special
about
where I ended up
where humans ended up it's okay we have
human level intelligence would you call
that AGI whatever we have it's GI look I
actually I don't really even like the
word AGI
um but general intelligence is defined
to be whatever humans have